que se espera que contenga este
histórico acuerdo para lograr un tratado
que frene la contaminación por los
plásticos
gracias señor mesa efectivamente lo que
se espera con el tratado es dar una
respuesta efectiva a un problema
ambiental de los más graves emergente
que significa para que tengamos
conciencia más presencia del tema de los
últimos desde años 1950 a la fecha se
estima que 8 billones de toneladas de
plástico que se han generado y
actualmente se tiene una producción
anual de 400 toneladas de plástico y se
espera en el 2040 si se siguen los
modelos de producción en consumo
actuales en cerca de 800 toneladas en el
año 2040 el 36 por ciento de este
volumen
se refiere al tema de envases embalajes
bolsas de un solo uso
y el 12% se queman
y se estima que alrededor del 20 3% base
de ecosistemas acuáticos más río lagos y
el coste económico que está tipo de
modelo implicada en la economía mundial
es de 2.5 billones de dólares y además
genera tiene efecto también para el
cambio climático
en esas estos problemas que son muy
concretos palpables afecta la economía
el ambiente de la sociedad requiere pues
una respuesta global por esa razón en la
asamblea de naciones unidas de medio
ambiente un edad que ha venido
trabajando esos temas ya desde el 2014
cuando se se solicitó un informe luego
alpe numa que lo generó luego el 2016 y
lo finalmente en esta asamblea en sí
dado el paso importante que es el de la
decisión de iniciaría un acuerdo global
que responda
el tema de la basura plata
esto significa significa que cambiar los
diseños cambiar los procesos de
producción cambiar los modelos también
se rehusó a analizar todo el ciclo de
vida del plástico así como también
intervenir en el proceso de
formalización está este acuerdo va a ser
trabajado por un comité de negociación
internacional que estaría empezando a
trabajar en el segundo semestre de este
año a más tardar y que tiene el mandato
de concluir sus trabajos en el 2024
convocando a todos los sectores
económicos sociales académicos de las
diversas regiones del mundo tenemos que
recoger efectivamente las expectativas y
demandas que se han venido prestando en
diversos foros con información muy
concreta y poder en consecuencia dar una
respuesta a este problema ambiental
global muy grave que afecta la salud y
la economía pero señor viceministro
ahora cuál sería el papel de los estados
será un instrumento vinculante
si un aspecto importante de este acuerdo
esa resolución octavo día es que el
instrumento jurídico internacional que
trabaja en general se está a negocios
internacionales para ser un instrumento
jurídico vinculante y tiene la
resolución además un conjunto de
componentes y que orienta y el proceso
lo
delimita no lo encausan estableciendo de
esa característica así como también los
mecanismos de desarrollo capacidades los
mecanismos para efectos de generar
financiamiento y mayores capacidades
para intervenir en este en estos temas
como se estila en el conjunto de
acuerdos internacionales y que a partir
de las lecciones aprendidas
efectivamente este enfoque de derechos
es decir desarrollo y capacidad de los
estados desarrollo capacidad de las
empresas de los consumidores es
fundamental necesitamos en el corto
plazo como ya se ha venido generando
generando dicho dicho sea de paso
cambios de prácticas en la producción en
el consumo porque además hay
alternativas recuerden las inflación del
36 por ciento del gran la entidad de
volumen de plástico solo uso